el departamento del tesoro de eeuu
emitió nuevas sanciones en contra de
funcionarios nicaragüenses cercanos y
leales a daniel ortega el vicepresidente
de la corte suprema de justicia un
diputado sandinista y un jefe policial
son los nuevos sancionados de parte de
eeuu el departamento del tesoro asegura
que estos funcionarios son responsables
de cooperar con un mecanismo de
información judicial y financiera para
castigar a opositores en nicaragua hasta
ahora ni el gobierno ni los sancionados
se han referido al tema aunque
recientemente en el parlamento los
diputados sandinistas aprobaron una ley
que abre la posibilidad de penalizar a
quienes el gobierno considere como
traidores de la patria oa quienes
celebren o soliciten este tipo de
sanciones hasta ahora eeuu ha sancionado
al menos a 27 funcionarios nicaragüenses
entre ellos a rosario murillo quien es
vicepresidenta y esposa de daniel ortega